at 8 30 a.m in afghanistan right now
where taliban fighters have captured the
city of jalalabad the capital of
nangarhar province it was one of two
remaining government strongholds
and really just a few hours drive away
from the capital kabul the collapse of
that eastern city would mean another
major setback for president
ashford put the taliban effectively in
control of most of the country earlier
the group's fighters seized a hugely
important commercial hub
and a government bastion marsuri sharif
the fall of afghanistan's fourth largest
city puts it in control of all northern
provinces and means that kabul is now
dangerously within reach of the armed
group
so with those forces crumbling in the
face of the taliban surge the u.s is
sending thousands of its troops back to
afghanistan but this is to support the
ongoing withdrawal
and to help evacuate american diplomats
and staff
president joe biden says he will support
a political settlement but insists any
assault by the taliban on the u.s
military will be met with what he called
a swift and strong response so the fear
now and i mentioned this a couple of
times is that the taliban is getting
very very close indeed
um to kabul have a look at this we've
got the google map for you afghanistan
as a whole there i'll
zoom in on kabul and i will drop a
little marker down
on the capital and let's
see where it takes us
in the region
heading in
this direction
uh sorry i've just lost it there there
we go mazara sharif
which we just heard about 300 kilometers
away uh kunduz 240 kilometers away and
then further to the south you've got
khasi 126 and jalalabad which we
mentioned incredibly close 115
kilometers as the crow flies from kabul
which is where charlotte bellis is
reporting from for us this morning
um
i mean it's just every 24 hours that we
talk to you at this point charlotte they
just the cities just keep falling
yeah the list is certainly growing it is
hard to keep up we are out to number 24
of the provincial capitals that have
fallen to the taliban of a total of 34
and that has happened in just nine days
now so the taliban certainly
steamrolling its way across the country
the two provinces that it has picked up
overnight and early this morning are
lagman and nangahar picked up their
provincial capitals
they are directly east of kabul they
actually boarded kabul to the east and
the government had been fighting
incredibly hard to keep those
not only are they close to kabul but
they essentially cut kabul off from
pakistan because their main trade route
had been to talk and crossing where you
have to go through ludman and you have
to go through nangahar to get to talkham
crossings and that is how a lot of the
city resupplied through that highway so
incredibly uh
worrying for the government now to have
that cut also logar the province
directly to the south of kabul fell on
friday and directly to the west of kabul
wardak is under heavy pressure i had a
video i got a video yesterday sewing
taliban on the roads and maiden shah
they've taken over some government
facilities there it's the main city uh
in wardak and it's only about 45 minute
drive from here so
kabul becoming increasingly encircled
the government under heavy pressure
ghani spoke yesterday briefly in an
address to the nation he was
the talk here had been that he might
resign but he offered
trying to kind of support uh the forces
and and say that he's looking after his
people and he does want to
consult with international and local
leaders but we understand negotiations
are going on behind the scene
uh on essentially his future and whether
he will stay on as president
tell me what it's like in kabul at the
moment
charlotte uh the fear obviously that uh
the taliban is getting ever closer but
how does that sort of manifest itself
there is panic growing definitely among
all sectors of the community
not only is kabul swelled in the last
week because there's been tens if not
hundreds of thousands of people swelling
into the city from the provinces and
you know staying with relatives that
kind of thing there's been idp camps
popping up in parks but then there's
also a lot of pressure on fuel that's
doubled in the last couple of months
which has sent food prices uh moving up
there was a run on banks yesterday i
drove past the bank there's 100 people
outside trying to get money out we
understand my colleagues also tried to
get money out they couldn't then we
understand that the government put a
limit on the amount of money that you
could withdraw yesterday um yeah
food prices going up ticket prices to
leave kabul the main route one of the
main routes is to istanbul it's usually
about 350
yesterday it was 2
400 and
one
interesting item that has gone up in
price burkas
more people here in kabul thinking they
may need a burka and the near future and
the prices for that are going up also
uh yeah and we're going to talk to a
guest hopefully about that shortly uh
charlotte some of the issues to do with
uh women at the moment
um
i'm interested in a little bit more of
what you're saying about
life in kabul about all the sheer number
of people coming in there i mean
where do people go i guess you you stay
with relatives you stay with friends
it's it's
anywhere that you could find shelter
[Music]
yeah a lot of people are just showing up
i mean i talked to one girl yesterday we
were actually going to do a story with
her about interpreters because she was a
us interpreter and she's applied for the
siv visa to get out she hasn't heard
anything from the us and she's becoming
increasingly panicked because she says
everyone knows i worked with the
americans and yet i haven't had an email
i don't know if i'm going to get out in
the next couple of weeks so we've been
talking to her we were meant to meet
with her and she said look 40 people
just showed up in my house from kunduz
and i have to feed them they're sleeping
on the floor and we're hearing of this
all the time
a lot of people in kabul are trying to
kind of raise donations for people
they've really got nowhere to go they're
too scared to go back to their own
provinces and now kabul's becoming
encircled and if they want to leave
kabul now that these provinces have
fallen to the east which was a main way
to get to pakistan they can't go out
that way as of this morning either so
it's flights and there's only only so
many planes leaving kabul and those
flights are incredibly expensive i mean
two thousand four hundred dollars one
way for one person if you've got a
family of eight and you you know you're
afghan on a normal salary there's no way
you could do that of course
okay thanks for all of that uh charlotte
unfortunately we haven't been able to
connect with our guests at the moment
but hopefully we can do that a little
later on